the internet can be weird my spoon is
too big
at its start long before corporate media
conglomerates controlled the online
experience the internet was like the
wild west full of independent artists
making weird experimental videos
unencumbered by advertisers or studio
heads browsing internet videos back in
the day was a roll of the dice sometimes
you hit gold sometimes you were just
traumatized and thankfully you can still
find new delightfully weird videos
online if you know where to look and
their weirdness is exactly the point
weird videos thrive on the internet
because with the exception of things
like adult swim they're the kind of
videos that people don't get to see in
traditional media the viral hit my spoon
is too big opens with a fake disclaimer
that these animations got rejected from
the fictional tv network the family
learning channel by framing the video as
unappealing to a family-friendly network
the video becomes more appealing to an
online audience because the viewer gets
to see something that apparently could
only exist on the internet and not on
advertiser friendly television as a
result a lot of viral internet videos
feel like tv programs that could never
make it to air they take conventional
media ranging from children's shows to
video games to political commentating
and present that media in ways we've
never seen before because the end result
of this reimagining ends up so strange
and seemingly random it's easy to
dismiss these kinds of internet videos
as just weird for the sake of being
weird but i think that sells some of
them short many of these videos address
big ideas have a strong understanding of
film language and use that surreal
weirdness to give their art greater
meaning to see what i mean let's start
with a classic
here's a story from north america the
video story from north america fits
nicely into the weird internet video
genre it's got creepy animation a catchy
song and quotable lyrics like many
animated internet videos it's partially
a parody of older children's cartoons it
looks similar to the hand-drawn style of
classic schoolhouse rock videos and it
similarly breaks the fourth wall to
teach the viewer a new word but the
animation in this goofy video is much
more intricate than the children's
animation it's inspired by human hands
are notoriously difficult to draw
because they're so small and detailed so
in a lot of traditional animation
characters either wear gloves or have
very simple fingers often times less
than five fingers to save time five
fingers ooh freak show but the
characters in story from north america
not only have a full set of fingers the
fingers themselves are incredibly
expressive and varied it's easy to get
lost in the weirdness of the animation
and forget that a lot of the individual
frames probably took hours to make and
shows like schoolhouse rock rarely do
something as complicated as a hand-drawn
three-dimensional camera move in the
same way that the animation goes further
than a children's show so too does the
video's message on the surface the video
seems to have a pretty simple message
about not killing a spider and
respecting all life it sounds like
something straight out of charlotte's
web but the video arrives at that
message in a much more interesting way
the song uses a sort of socratic back
and forth dialogue between the dad and
the sun to arrive at the logical
conclusion that there's no real
justification for killing a spider
charlotte's web says that we should
sympathize with the spider because she
is an exceptional friend to the pig but
story from north america says that
spiders do not need to be exceptional to
be protected they're worthy of
protection because we can see our own
humanity in them to treat spiders
otherwise would be a great moral failing
showing how humanity's superiority
complex leads to harmful pride and a
thirst for blood i particularly like
this shot of michelangelo's david
breaking apart as the dad debunks his
son's arguments it shows how the dad's
critique challenges the supposed
superiority of the human form this video
is certainly too weird for television
but it's much more than that the
ambitious artistry and genuinely
thought-provoking message go beyond to
the simpler television shows it's
riffing on and some people have gone
even further with the video's main ideas
for example if the video has such a
universal theme why is it called story
from north america there's a theory
online that suggests the story is an
allegory for the united states fear of
nuclear annihilation the standoff
between the boy and the spider could
symbolize the standoff between the
united states and the soviet union
there's imagery to support this idea
like showing bombs with mushroom clouds
the christian imagery and the dads fear
that they will wake up the neighbors i'm
sure some people will scoff at the idea
of giving this video such deep analysis
but why is that i think videos like this
one don't get looked at enough because
they appear simple and childish when in
reality they're as skillfully made and
as full of meaning as any traditional
media but in terms of weirdness this
video is only the tip of the iceberg
let's get weirder with one of the most
famous weird internet videos of all time
what's your favorite idea
mine is being creative the first episode
of the web series don't hug me i'm
scared is another internet video in the
style of a children's show the video
starts off with a seemingly innocent
lesson on how to be creative and to
sense into disturbing surreal madness
the video shows the malice behind
traditional kids programming the
sketchbook claims to be teaching how to
be creative but she never actually does
when the puppets do creative things on
their own she shuts them down like when
the yellow puppet paints his own picture
or when she decides that only certain
colors are creative green is not a
creative color instead of teaching
individual creativity she's teaching
them to conform to her idea of
creativity when they're all staring at
the clouds they don't find anything
exciting about them until the sketchbook
puts on a monocle and then they describe
the clouds in unison the insincerity of
the lesson gets further exposed in this
shot when the camera does a 360 and
reveals the production team making the
show it's such a jarring shot because it
exposes an angle of the set we normally
never see it shows that behind the
bright colors and carefree tone of a
children's show there's always a team in
control and their goal is often to
maintain the status quo not to teach
anything new the ensuing chaos exposes
the malicious subconscious of children's
programming programming that doesn't
always have the best interest of the
children in mind don't hug me i'm scared
came out over 10 years ago but the ideas
it addresses have aged incredibly well
it highlights the potential problems of
not looking closely at the media we show
kids in a way the video predicted future
controversies on youtube like the
scandal where videos got tagged as
children friendly but were actually
completely inappropriate sometimes even
creepier than don't hug me i'm scared
and to this day children's programming
doesn't always have the best interest of
children in mind cocoa melon is an
incredibly popular kid's youtube channel
but its primary interest isn't to teach
children valuable lessons like
creativity it's just to keep their
attention and sell that child's
attention to advertisers the great thing
about shows like sesame street is that
the creators establish transparent goals
for educating children on certain topics
don't hug me i'm scared exposes how kids
often watch media that lacks the care or
supervision we probably wish kids shows
had this video is a perfect example of
how the weirdness of internet videos can
make them more meaningful don't hug me
i'm scared isn't weird just for the sake
of it it's weirdness sheds light on the
weirdness of actual children's
programming story from north america and
don't hug me i'm scared are two older
weird internet classics but even as the
online world has become more and more
corporatized the genre lives on
today's weird internet videos have
continued to evolve while still
retaining core elements of the genre
nowadays many weird animation videos use
modern 3d animation software instead of
hand drawn or flash animation and the
new technology still achieves that
classic internet creepiness one great
example of this new style is on the
channel amon animations a mod animations
is a political meme animation channel
with bizarre exaggerated depictions of
political commentators like story from
north america and don't hug me i'm
scared amon animations is too weird for
conventional media and it similarly
re-contextualizes media that viewers are
familiar with in this case it
re-contextualizes the political
discourse we see online the channel does
have creepy children's cartoon
animations but it mostly incorporates
nostalgia from video games like metal
gear solid the videos often reference
metal gear solid directly and reuse some
of its visual motifs like the glowing
red eyes and the larger-than-life
villainous characters also like metal
gear solid amada animations has a strong
understanding of film language in the
video jordan peterson 12 more rules
peterson travels between hallucinations
as he grapples with an inner conflict
when the camera cuts it makes sure to
stay on one side of the space to keep
the character's spatial relationship
consistent the video also maintains
discontinuity when switching between
hallucinations to make the transition
seamless but when the tension starts to
rise the cuts get more frequent and the
camera breaks this spatial rule jumping
around to the actors in the exact same
way that classic horror movies do it the
video also uses other horror techniques
like distorting the frame with dolly
zooms and exaggerating human faces in
impossible ways but amani animations
uses 3d software to go even further than
conventional movies do the dolly zoom
and camera moves are even creepier and
exaggerated and from his very first
video he's made his characters larger
than life by literally having them grow
and shrink and like other great weird
internet videos there's a meaning behind
the weirdness in jordan peterson 12 more
rules peterson has to choose between two
paths for his life his first option
which he describes in a speech is to
teach people to grow up like pinocchio
he wants to help his followers break
free of the strings that control them
but his other more nefarious option is
to join other reactionary pundits and
cash in on his celebrity puppets are a
recurring symbol in the video peterson
says people start out as puppets and
then become real beings but ironically
his followers in the video act exactly
like puppets and they want peterson to
control them my master
please wake up for
the conflict between controlling his
followers for profit and helping them
lose their strings reaches a crescendo
when peterson wakes up from his coma on
one side there's a cow that has the same
red eyes as the reactionary
personalities it's a literal cash cow
that grows larger as it tells peterson
to think of the money on the other side
there's geppetto and jiminy cricket
symbols of his desire to help his
audience of pinocchios and in turn free
himself from the pressures of shallow
success and greed the video establishes
these symbols so effectively that in the
end we don't have to be told which path
peterson chose the video can just show
it he has transformed into a puppet
amana animations proves that weird
imagery online can mean something not
only are these videos incredibly
executed but the weird puppets and
animals act as concrete symbols and the
overall weirdness better illustrates the
impact that political commentators have
their rhetoric by design creates chaos
and outrage online and the freaky
imagery of oman animations shows what
that chaos can feel like it's this
meaning behind the weirdness that
elevates videos like this one to the
status of art
[Music]
from the beginning the internet has been
a refuge for experimental art that
couldn't exist in traditional media
nowadays corporations are trying to make
the internet less weird and more normal
because normal means more advertisers
and more advertisers means more money
and that's not necessarily a bad thing
i'm obviously grateful for the
infrastructure that makes channels like
mine possible but i have a deep
appreciation for the wonderful
playground that the internet started off
with and it's from this strange place
that we see the online world at its most
creative and thankfully there's still
space online for the weirdness open
source software makes animating more
accessible than ever and channels like
aman animations get funding directly
from fans which is a great way to keep
these delightful not advertiser friendly
videos alive and we should celebrate
these works of art because they're the
kind of videos that make the internet
the internet so the next time you see
some strange viral video consider that
it might be more than just weird it
might also be art very very weird
arty and daddy
[Applause]
[Music]
you